siete mil 550 millones
esa es la cantidad de habitantes que
somos hoy en día en este planeta
a esta hora seguramente tal vez más
nacieron más
o menos no sé para qué
nunca se sabe a ciencia cierta pero
estoy seguro que al menos todos los que
estamos acá presentes hemos pasado por
situaciones incómodas
y vaya saber cómo la re salió cada uno
de ustedes no eso es lo que me preocupa
este problema social que nos hace perder
de muchas cosas cumpleaños eventos
trabajos compras
y hablar con gente no sé hablar con la
persona que nos gusta y de tanto perder
nos convertimos en seres que no somos en
nuestra cosa o en una cosa
en lo sucesivo presentaré mi visión
sobre estas situaciones incómodas
situaciones críticas a nivel individual
dentro de un contexto social o sea
cuando hacemos referencia a situaciones
críticas a nivel individual planteamos
la ruptura de un alguien
de lo que es humanamente civilizado o
sea cuando un ciudadano o una ciudadana
se desubica accidentalmente del ritmo y
paisaje habitual
no se preocupen
a continuación voy a indagar con
ejemplos de casos reales reales que les
van a ayudar a ustedes a la construcción
empírica de los conceptos antes dados
está bien vamos al caso número uno el
primer caso pueden marcarse dentro de la
tipología víctimas gravitacionales con
impacto físico dentro de un contexto
social de alto grado de exposición
o sea
cuando te caes en la calle bueno
vamos a vamos a hablar del conocido caso
de un bancario de 57 años de la ciudad
de santa fe de acá nomás y para
preservar su privacidad obvio vamos a
llamarlo por otro nombre porque es un
conocido bancario así que lo vamos a
llamar
pepe pepe
se estaba dirigiendo a su descanso
laboral
a su ya habitual almuerzo cuando padeció
los efectos de un desequilibrio
inesperado
que lo dejó expuesto desnudo e indefenso
en un contexto público la secuencia
puede describirse de la siguiente manera
pp
sufrió la suma de estos factores la
humedad de nuestro queridísimo litoral
es que la que estamos viviendo ahora por
ejemplo sobre un porcelanato
excelentemente ilustrado de la entrada
del restorán más unos zapatos italianos
de suela lisa
que a pepe le encantaba utilizar los
días lunes
lunes
todo esto eso que pepe termine en el
suelo sin escala social que termino de
panza en el piso saben cuál fue la forma
de resolver de pepe esta situación
escapando
desapareció se pudo observar que en un
acto de desesperación y bochorno pp se
levantó rápidamente y desapareció
emprendió el escape hacia otro lugar el
más lejano que pudo nunca más obviamente
se lo volvió a ver en ésta rectoral
se pudo observar en los presentes debido
a esa fuga tan bochornosa vergüenza
ajena
la vergüenza ajena se debe a que uno
siente preocupación por la vergüenza
ginés cuando vemos que el sujeto es
consciente de su comportamiento ridículo
vieron cuando vemos a una persona que
este pobre tipo está haciendo el
ridículo bueno esa es la vergüenza ajena
la vergüenza empática que es lo que
sintieron cuando se cayó pp se debe a
que sentimos empatía por una persona que
pone un riesgo su personalidad frente a
un público no cuente a la gente pues y
por eso
que es diferente al jefe pobre tipo
trágame tierra o no
esa es la diferencia entre la vergüenza
empática y la deferencia ajena como pudo
haber resuelto esta situación pp chicos
como lo pudo resuelto ese pudor
levantado se pudo haberse acogido el
traje pudo haber entrado al restaurante
buscar complicidad con alguna de las
tantas miradas que lo observaban y
seguramente provocar alguna risa
almorzar como lo había tenido planeado y
convertir esa situación tan incómoda
sobre todo para él en una posible
anécdota que seguro después contaría a
sus amigos a sus familiares compañeros
de trabajo cuando llegue vamos al caso
número dos al ejemplo número dos en este
caso vamos a conocer el desarrollo del
conocido impacto que encefálico y nasal
contra superficies traslúcidas de alto
grado de transparencia
qué es
exacto cuando te chocas una puerta de
vidrio
o cuando te chocas una vidriera
en el clásico acercamiento excesivo para
observar un precio o un producto
quejando
generalmente estos casos están envueltos
dentro de un contexto socio comercial
que posicionan al sujeto en crisis en un
estado de exhibición extremo e incluso a
veces queda grabado porque los comercios
tienen cámaras que se ríen los de
seguridad no chicos es muy feo
también dentro de estos ámbitos
comerciales es muy común encontrarnos
con la clásica caída de productos al
suelo sin querer
tic tac
generalmente estos serían supermercados
o no para estos casos siempre recomiendo
tener una criatura al lado a quien
echarle la culpa que tengáis
también está la nunca deseada caída de
productos al suelo sin querer en cadena
que es cuando tengo
esto generalmente está vivido por
sujetos que están en los extremos de las
edades no a criaturas que son inquietas
y tocan todo y a los ancianos que
también son muy inquietos
y tocan todos se rían
muchos de los que estamos acá presentes
vamos a llegar a ser ancianos
incluso veo que algunos han llegado
felicitaciones muy bien aplausos
pero bueno perdón volvamos a los
topetazos contra los vidrios este es el
caso de una uruguaya de 42 años que
también vamos a llamar por otro nombre
le vamos a llamar maria maria se estaba
alojando en un reconocido hotel de las
playas de brasil de acá del sur santa
catarina ella estaba ahí después de una
breve siesta se despertó con el
incontrolable antojo de zambullirse en
el mar así que algo dormida y apurada
emprendió su trayectoria directamente
hacia la playa
si hay algo que caracteriza a estos
sujetos que se dan topetazos contra los
vidrios es la seguridad
ellos van seguros hacia el cristal como
bueno maria maria no fue la excepción
maria no fue la excepción así que se la
veía muy segura de a donde ella iba o al
menos a donde ella creía que iba
seguramente el mar de fondo el día
demasiado claro y los vidrios chicos
excelentemente limpios muy bien ayudaron
a que maría termine estampada en la
puerta de ingreso no tengo una
calcomanía para
ahora lo verdaderamente extraño fue
saben cuál fue la forma de resolver este
caso de mariah saben cuál fue dicho es
rarísimo quedó grabado la insistencia
mariah de un paso hacia atrás
y volvió
volvió a querer como si no el mundo está
equivocado yo estoy uno cierto acá no
hay cristales más
le suena familiar esto chocarse siempre
contra la misma pared insistir si hay
cositas que trabajar en
todo esto provocó que maría termine en
una explosión de palabrotas y enojos y
quejas contra el conserje del hotel
diciéndole qué haces con esto
es una familiar esto es echarle la culpa
a los demás familias cositas que
trabajar así
es también importante reconocerlo
sigamos
como se pudo observar en maría y en los
presentes un leve aumento de la
temperatura facial o sea que se pusieron
colorados
rojo se puso amarilla y todos hay
estudios que afirman que nos ponemos
colorados debido a las terminaciones
nerviosas y a los vasos sanguíneos que
se dilatan y a la aceleración del ritmo
cardíaco sobre todo en situaciones de
pudor vergüenza inseguridad ira
excitación
esto más que nada en personalidades que
son tímidas introvertidas inseguras
temerosas la
la falta de autoestima
y el miedo a hacer el ridículo son
pilares en estas situaciones
también a modo de dato curioso existen
casos extremos de electro fobia saben
que es la nitro fobia pueden responder
gracias gracias por participar la
electro fobia es un caso extremo así
como existen fobias a las arañas a las
alturas a los payasos también existe la
fobia a ponerse colorado
pero como tienen miedo ya se ponen
colorados chicos
o sea si ponen colorados por mí va a
ponerse colorados y empiezan como una
especie de intermitencia entre el
colorado y su color de nacimiento por
gente no que uno lo ve de 7-1 se corre
por las dudas y no sé por no ser bien
chico df o bueno
como pudo haber resuelto esta situación
maría
ella en primer lugar pudo haber aceptado
que te equivocaste y no echarle la culpa
a los demás
pudo haber aceptado su protagonismo esa
hermosísima escena que le alegró la
tarde a toda la playa
y reírse también con todos seguir
adelante meterse en el mar como lo había
planeado vamos a ir al último caso el
caso número 3 es mientos
involuntarios de proyectiles salivales
sobre la corporalidad de los objetos
circundantes
a ver si alguien sabe de qué se trata de
esto
sí sí cuando escupes a alguien sin
quererlo al hablar
o
esto es peor cuando compartís un poquito
de lo que comes sin que nadie te lo pida
gracias no gracias
vamos este es el caso de un rosarino
muy guapo el a quien llamaremos danielle
ni esta ni
estaba saliendo con una chica hacía
poquito todavía no había salido era todo
vía internet
y no se le ocurrió mejor idea daniel en
su primera cita que invita a la una la
del día
chicos jamás en una primera cita una
heladería
es básico están todos los libros jamás
sal de la avería chico en una primera
cita
en fin esos llegaron a la alegría ella
pidió crema de cielo horrible
y menta granizada clásico
elpidio
banana split chocolates con almendras
almendras así eran así
danielle fue víctima de los nervios
lógicos de una primera cita porque
imagínate bueno una primera cita tenés
que estar tratando de sostener una
conversación medianamente interesante
pero no aburrida inteligente pero no
demasiado elevada graciosa pero sin
pasarse de la raya espontánea pero sin
asustar a la chica que tienes
y además tiene que estar tratando de
sostener que el helado no se techo en
pleno verano rosarino es una situación
inhumana
es inhumano jamás a una heladería en una
primera cita chico de básico
todo esto provocó que una de esas
enormes almendras se le instalar en la
garganta danielle provocando una
herramiento se atoró decía mi diosa
toros a toro bueno se le mete una cosa
que le provocó un aumento que
interrumpió la paz y la alegría de la
heladería porque empezó a toser como
loco cada vez más morocha salió
corriendo a buscar agua ciabogas
chicos horrible
chicos de verdad fue horrible
danielle logró liberarse de la almendra
convirtiéndola en un proyectil
que se fue a instalar directamente en el
hermoso vestido de su compañerita
la almendra no iba sola
así que no se quedó quieta cuando llego
al vestido no hizo una pequeña
trayectoria dejándole una marca
cuál fue
fue traumático de verdad
cuál fue la forma de resolver el daño de
esta situación el silencio
se quedó callado 30 minutos en silencio
estuvo en la heladería
y ella terminó oyó de comercio de la
dieta
qué linda web
después los largos en como dos minutos
ella propuso caminar
caminaron por pellegrini
sin tomarse de la mano
la acompañó hasta la casa le dio un beso
en la mejilla y nunca más la volví a ver
como pudo haber resuelto esta situación
daniel crisis pasado si él no hubiese
optado por el silencio hubiese
verbalizado la situación contarle a su
compañera como una anécdota recién
salida del horno
y reírse de sí mismo a lo mejor tendría
novia quién sabe
luego de poner estos casos estoy seguro
que la mayoría de los que estamos acá
presentes y no es que todos hemos vivido
hemos vivido situaciones incómodas como
esta incluso peores que nos daría pudor
contarlas en público
pero es ahí donde me quiero detener como
vimos en todos estos casos hay otras
formas de resolverlos hay formas más
amenas más graciosas pero para llegar a
eso primero tenemos que reconocer cuán
vulnerables somos y saber de que no
podemos tener el control de todo lo que
nos pasa
podemos reconocer nuestros miedos y
debilidades para poder trabajar en ellos
y así que no se conviertan en trabas o
bloqueos que nos impidan vivir
situaciones nuevas
porque en realidad es en mi caso
yo soy una persona muy tímida
a mí me da mucha vergüenza hablar en
público
incluso ahora siento un poco de miedo
estando frente a ustedes
pero ante la propuesta de dar esa charla
yo busque alternativas para no escaparme
de nuevo para no hacerle caso a todo eso
que soy que construye estas piezas de
personaje que no soy me puse este traje
que me lo prestaron
me hicieron este nudo que no lo sé hacer
y yo decidí caerme delante de todos para
que me habían levantar
yo ya sé que ustedes lo saben
pero a veces por diferentes razones como
la rutina o la preocupación por querer
encajar y que no acepten socialmente a
veces se nos olvida así que vengo a
recordarle todos todos me si el papá el
que os quiero acá enfrente yo vos todos
somos vulnerables todos todos nos caemos
todos nos equivocamos no solamente
tenemos el derecho de equivocarnos sino
también la necesidad de caernos para
poder hacernos más fuertes
el problema está cuando te caes siempre
el mismo lugar y cuando te chocas
siempre con la misma cosa y de echar la
culpa al mundo pero si aprendemos a
sacarle provecho a estas situaciones
vamos a poder crecer y aprender a ser
protagonistas cuando salgan de acá y
sufran de alojamientos transitorios de
hortalizas bucodentales
o sea cuando cuando hablas con un pedazo
de rúcula en los dientes y nadie te
avisa
cómo vas a reaccionar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]